[Music]
welcome everyone to another episode of
kiwi talks my guest today is an amazing
video game writer uh who's worked on
franchises such as half-life psychonauts
portal
he's also got many other talents i'd
like to welcome eric walpole how you
doing
i'm good i'm
curious to hear about all these other
talents that i've got well
didn't you used to be like a database
programmer before yeah a writer yeah i
mean i wasn't yeah yes i was in fact
a lot of my uh
bringing game writing involves database
programming as well uh it's because
that's
a huge piece of it is just there's so
much stuff to keep organized you almost
have to
have
somebody who gets a lot of pleasure out
of keeping uh data organized to uh
to do this job because it can quickly
overwhelm you uh
the the number of lines and making sure
everything's
organized
so so you're very good at time
management i would assume as a result
time meant no i mean unless you mean do
i know the exact moment when i've
procrastinated to the point where i need
to start now or i need to quit i know
how to do that uh but yeah no it usually
turns out being i actually watch the
or listen to the podcast you did with
josh and i never knew that he was
talking about how much he uh
he uh
sort of well he i guess he didn't really
talk about how much he procrastinates
but his time management sounded um as
bad as mine as well
so
yeah well i've heard
that writers constantly procrastinate
that's kind of like
the thing you do when you're a writer
yeah that is absolutely i i don't know
any writer that we've ever worked with
that
just likes to roll up their sleeves and
get going there's always a lot of
doing anything you can think of to put
off uh writing in fact i remember
this was way back in the day working on
psychonauts with tim and a lot of times
we wrote separately but sometimes we'd
sit in a room and write together
and a lot of that time was just spent
uh
talking about um
uh what was it uh the next game which
was uh shoot why can't i remember the
name now the na the game after
psychonauts with jack black
uh brutal legend yeah like you would
waste time
not you know just talking about bru i i
ended up not working on brutal legend
but you know we we would talk about it
as a means to
put off working on on psychonauts
right right so in terms of the writing
process for you what would you say is
the hardest part is it just coming up
with the initial ideas is it like coming
up with a name for a character the
actual script of it like
i mean
all of the above
it's all kind of tough we try not to
agonize too much over names
um uh you know
you can get bogged down
just worrying over those so maybe i i'm
gonna say that's one of the easier parts
is coming up with names but uh
a hard part is because a lot of times
uh
especially with i have a
jay pinkerton's my writing partner and
that's written with him for a long time
and i've always tended to like to write
with someone whether it was chat or tim
or whoever
uh i like to do it as a group so one of
the harder things just keeping the
energy up like to just keep writing
because it's really easy to kind of get
into this kind of low energy grumpy kind
of
mood where nothing productive is
happening so some of it's just
maintaining a an energy level to keep
everybody you know going
right and is there like additional
things like red bull or something
no no
uh
it's i've heard this about other writing
rooms it usually involves you juice it
by somebody will just say something
horrible like really really
bad not not
nasty or mean to the other person but
just you're just gonna make there's some
jokes that aren't gonna make it
into the final product that just kind of
they're so shocking that they just sort
of juice the the rum so to speak
right
makes sense
is it true
that even though that you're a writer
you hate writing
i hate it i mean i
yeah yeah i guess i don't like the
process when it's going well it's fine
or if you're together
uh and you're having good time and
things are sort of rolling once things
are rolling
you kind of get into this fugue state a
little bit where time passes and you
don't notice it passing but the lead up
to that is is pretty painful the
starting
it sort of to get that and sometimes it
never quite gets to that point but
sometimes it does there's a i mean this
is the
the cliche but it's true is you like
having written you don't like writing
but that's true of any job i think you
like having done it but not the actual
person
yeah yeah yeah
so with um
with any game how far in the process do
you actually start the writing because i
know when i spoke to josh he mentioned
like on portal 2 that you didn't want to
come in and start writing until
later within the production cycle
because you don't want to write
something
and then it's just made completely
obsolete because of design changes
yeah
uh i did hear josh said that that isn't
actually 100 of the reason because
that's just a part of the game making
processes every discipline ends up doing
things that just get thrown out so
but it's not always
in terms of the way we do it it's not or
the way i like to work it's not super
product like the game should come first
and then we start applying a story to
the game so we only want to write
as much as is helpful to
push the game design along and a lot of
times that doesn't have that just
doesn't make sense till later on
you know in portal 2 since it was a
sequel we were sort of
poking around at what might be
interesting early on but the actual
rolling up your sleeves and and if
they're doing
some
tests which they always are a lot of
times we'll throw some some dialogue in
there or something just to kind of as
sort of placeholder
uh
just to
not even to see how the dialogue works
but just to sort of grease the wheels to
make it feel a little bit more like a
real thing you know as someone's testing
it
but
it's usually pretty
late
or late maybe late isn't the right maybe
halfway through production
is when the really the really intense
writing starts and then it goes
all the way through
to the very end usually
so was it always mapped out as like say
portal 2 taking years taking place years
after paul to one how many years is it
supposed to be by the way
i i don't i i've not even been quite i
don't know a long time we never really
decided it's a long time you didn't have
a concrete just it's a it's a it's a
long time yeah
uh
that's the other thing try not to write
yourself into a corner that you then are
good is going to cause problems for you
because we we weren't sure if was maybe
someday there's another portal or
something happens and if we say it's
if it doesn't help us to say it's
100 years in the future or 10 years in
the future or a thousand years in the
future if there isn't a problem that
that actually solves then why even say
it because we may want it
we we may have an idea later on for the
next game
not that there ever will be i don't know
if there ever will be next game but
where did it be the next game though
don't you
oh yeah i would love to yeah i'd work on
another portal in a second but i
yeah i can't do it unfortunately by
myself so i mean i like working with i
mean i can't like make it happen well
you must have a bit of leverage at valve
don't you you can you can advocate for
it oh i could advocate for it i would
not gonna do it i'm gonna help but i
could do it uh
it might help a little bit but
uh
the problem is with 300 employees and
there isn't you know i i don't know
exactly the breakdown like how many of
them are
on the production side versus steam
business side versus
legal versus whatever yeah of course
there's only so there's a lot of
opportunity cost to uh taking you know
75 people and trying to get a game made
like there's you know as much as it
seems like valve often isn't
there's just a bunch of people sitting
around
you know sipping gin and tonics by a
pool everybody's working they're working
all the time it's just you don't always
see the it doesn't always end up coming
out or it comes out years later
it gets turned into something else so
uh there's everybody is accounted for i
guess is what i'm saying people are all
doing something so you almost have to
take them you have to
it's like a revolution you'd have to
you'd have to stir up a bunch of people
to
leave what they're currently working on
and come work on something else in this
case it would be portal three
yeah i mean it would be a money maker
yeah that's what i'm saying
hey you're preaching to the choir here
you'd make some money uh the problem is
you would make money but is it
what kind of money will you make you
know
uh you're gonna make
counter-strike go money probably not uh
but having said that maybe every game
doesn't need to make counter-strike go
money
you know gabe if you're listening uh
[Laughter]
maybe maybe well because maybe it's
enough
well there's a bit of a misperception i
think sometimes with people just think
everyone at valve is not doing anything
because you know games don't come out at
a rapid rate
which is obviously not true i mean
obviously you guys doing a lot of stuff
behind the scenes from steam deck and
managing steam in and of itself and then
there's other stuff on top of that i'm
sure yeah and there's games or
stuff that gets cancelled there's
prototypes canceled is even
too
top-down too too
authoritarian a word i guess
sometimes it stuff just falls apart like
it becomes
clear to people that this just isn't
working out uh or
like
i was just describing something's kind
of going along and maybe it's not going
it's not turning into the thing that
everybody had hoped it would turn into
but it's still a group of people and
you're all sort of working on it
together
and you don't always want to admit that
and then slowly people peel off to
go work on something else that's been
proposed it makes it sound uh
insane and it it makes more sense when
you're there it's not as as chaotic as
as uh i'm probably making it sound well
no it can't be if
because obviously every product that's
been released by valve is is great
you know
usually there's nothing they're bad
yeah there's a high quality yeah there's
a high quality bar and part of that is
because
by the time something reaches
like full production mode there's a lot
of buy-in from people and there are
people working on it because they want
to work on it right
so
yeah there's a lot of enthusiasm usually
it in that middle part and then there's
just despair and
by the end you're just you're
everybody's sad and ready to be done
isn't that what happened with portal 2
there was like this big team and then it
kind of kept getting smaller and smaller
smaller until yeah down until like a
quite a small team
it was on the verge of falling apart the
way
various valve projects fall apart and it
did it a bunch of people left to go work
on
uh
other things at some point
left 4 dead 2 took a lot of people but
the exodus had already sort of started
before then
um
and there was just a little core group
left
uh josh and uh
josh i think he mentioned this on the
podcast that they almost even though
they were technically still working on
portal 2 they actually jump ship
garrett and josh and i think john
guthrie and maybe somebody else to make
a
it's like portal one for the xbox or
something yeah i think
josh
mentioned that yeah um but then
and then things started to uh get some
if i i don't even know if i have the
chronology right in my head but
then things started to pick up again
a lot of it had to do with going back to
portals uh
there originally it was a different
mechanism
or something yeah yeah it was f-stop and
then it went back to portal
uh and it started to get traction and
people started coming back
and then we sort of all stopped except
for maybe a handful to ship left 4 dead
2 i don't remember how many months that
took a bunch of people jumped on at the
end of left 4 dead 2.
um
that was kind of an almost all hands on
deck sort of situation uh but at that
point there was enough buy-in on portal
2 that it wasn't really in danger of
just falling apart it was pretty clear
like left 4 dead 2 was going to ship it
wasn't some long tail game that
everybody was gonna have to you know
some
skeleton crew is gonna have to work on
for the rest of their lives everybody
would come back who was originally
working and then that same thing happens
with portal 2 is that it's getting close
you know as it got closer and closer to
shipping more and more people would jump
on
uh
to help get it out the door
um you know by the end it was a big
production i think there was
all the
uh
the production side was working on
portal 2 with us so there was still a
crew working on dodo was being worked on
at the time
right it's possible when portal 2
shipped
dota was
actually out like in beta or something
but maybe not i can't remember now um
but anyway and then portal 2 ships and
then everybody moves on i don't know
what they moved on to after that but uh
actually remember what i moved on to we
did a couple of dlcs but that was with
smaller groups maybe that's what we were
working on after that anyway yeah
portal 2 came
pretty close to
just being if not
killed you know maybe it would have been
come back again in
in some form later on but it would have
been that team would have just disbanded
and somebody might take another run at
it years later or whatever that's crazy
to me because it's so acclaimed and in
my opinion i think it's a valve's best
game still to this day oh well i'm happy
that you think that thank you the um uh
because i did it all myself um the uh i
think
uh
you may not have felt that way about the
earlier version that people were
abandoning right it that was a different
well that's so that's game development
though trial and testing
yeah it's the games are bad until
until they're uh yeah i remember reading
an interview with
cliffy b cliff blazinski at one point
i'm paraphrasing now where he was
talking about people say oh all you do
is get to play games all day but he was
like no what i get to do is go in and
play a really terrible game and it's up
to me to try and figure out how to make
it good which is a you know it's a
daunting
um problem to solve totally
um
i know with the initial idea of portal 2
you were struggling a bit until uh you
came up with the idea of wheatley and
that kind of caused a compounding effect
of
ideas to pop up didn't it in terms of
making the story aspects of it work yeah
i'm trying to think wheatley was in
there
early on but i think what unlocked stuff
was
we had a longer game than portal 2 and
we were
we didn't really want glados to be the
antagonist the whole time
uh a because that was just sort of gonna
actually i was gonna say that would
track portal one but it would actually
be more reductive and uh even than
portal one because in portal one she was
sort of neutral for a while and then
became
uh an antagonist but
uh what
the thing that unlocked everything was
when we came up with the idea that
wheatley
was the core that was
designed to be stupid and kind of dampen
glados's intelligence and that he would
take over the facility
um and then give you and glados
something to kind of
uh butt up against uh
and again that
that's one of those things where we were
sort of struggling and like wheatley was
gonna died uh like he sort of
seems like he dies gets killed by glados
in portal 2
but at one point he was just dead
and then i can't remember what we were
going to do at that point but um
but the idea of him coming back
and the
intelligence dappening core like that
all came in one session where we were
sitting around talking about it and it
is that thing where sometimes you have
an idea
that
i'm not going to say is so good because
i mean that i pat myself on the back but
it's so
perfect for the problem you're trying to
solve or fit so well that suddenly just
idea after idea starts coming out and so
like a lot of the back half of the game
broad strokes wise came out of you know
one
two or three hour session in the middle
of this three year project or whatever
ah
that's fascinating stuff in terms of the
dialogue like how long does it take you
to fine-tune i mean because
well i mean i imagine with us wheatley
for example stephen merchant must have
ad-libbed a lot of stuff
um
sort of yeah he
you know we obviously let uh steven
merchant ad-lib what he wanted
we also spent a lot of time
listening to i mean we cast him it
wasn't like some cold cast where he was
just like steve merchant and he
you know uh we didn't know who he was uh
we we spent a lot of time listening to
his podcasts and stuff like that and try
and
write to
his voice and so a lot of that was
written his delivery in the stop and
start uh
kind of just like the flow of his uh
speech patterns
was him and he would improvise in the
studio but a lot of times while it was
really funny he would throw in a lot of
like pop culture references and stuff
that we didn't um
we couldn't use because it just wasn't
what we were looking for there but again
much like with the writing in the studio
you want to keep the energy up as well
so him just going off and riffing on
something even if it was unusable was
was usually good just to keep everybody
you know
doesn't sound like a lot but these four
four hours is kind of the maximum
union-wise recording session but it's
also four hours is a huge amount of time
to be in their uh recording dialogue
it's just it's just
it's really uh
you wouldn't think it would be draining
and tiring uh to do you know kind of sit
in a room and
both act or direct for four hours but
it's it's rough uh
uh i can't remember what i said so yeah
there was some improv but we all
wheatley's lines were
written out i mean
also not just
because we're control freaks but because
it's
kind of bad form to just go in with an
actor and be like hey can you just make
some stuff up for like they got enough
work to do like you need to
provide them with with the material
uh that they need
uh to do this and i think you know with
steven merchant i don't remember now i
bet it was
you know
over the course of three years and again
you know he's front and center in the
game but in terms of development
maybe we had five sessions with him of
four hours each you know over the course
of the whole thing so you have to be
even though i'm saying he's improvising
and going off off script a little bit
you only get so many shots at it like
you got to have your
you got to pick your battles and have
your stuff set up pretty well before you
go in because you tend to not get a lot
of opportunities um
to mess around with stuff and it's not
like putting on a play where you're
going to have a lot of rehearsals and
things
another thing is we try and as often as
possible like with stephen merchant or
with uh nate bargetsy
in a
desk job
uh we try and write to people's
a voice that's kind of natural to them
you know we're not gonna
unless it's they're really
no we we typically try to
you know write to something that we know
they're gonna be able to do but you
always find things that they do better
or worse so you know the the fourth
session is usually or this even the
second session is usually a lot more
productive than the first session where
you're
kind of making notes and figuring out
what even though you think you have a
good idea what the actor can and can't
do
uh
or what they're better or worse at uh
you tend to you know
it becomes a lot clearer after the first
session
uh we always like to oh go ahead no no
no
you keep going keep going i
and just
we always try and do
you know like for steve merchant who was
in um
uh lives in london and based in london
uh
so even pre-covet obviously we we did
those sessions remotely except for the
first one we always try and do the first
session in person with an actor just so
everybody can see each other and you
know you're all real people to each
other and uh it's just
it's a good for relationship building
for them the future session everybody
kind of knows everybody a little bit
yeah it makes sense makes sense
so in terms of i mean
directing
in general because is it just you
directing or how many of you are
actually directing him it depends on
who's you know in the uh
for the
[Music]
so typically it's
it's always me and jay pinkerton um and
uh for portal we had uh bill van buren
who
uh
was um
he worked at valve and did a lot of
sound stuff and he was just good at
being
in the um
in the room a nice
calm voice uh
but you know for some older tf stuff it
was would be me in chet
uh
but usually somebody takes the lead and
often nowadays it's just jay because
he's better at it and i pace around
behind him and then we talk about it
uh you know if we have any notes or
anything um but you we always try and
give
you know there's one person who's kind
of quote-unquote director just so there
isn't seven well there there's never
seven people in there but so there just
are two people just
shouting random things
uh
so um
yeah so it's you know occasionally or
and but then jay used to smoke so there
would be a little change in the guard
because he can only go about 45 minutes
without getting a cigarette so he'd have
to go outside and get a cigarette and
then i'd take over for a little bit
right
but um
yeah uh
makes sense makes sense yeah so
was it the same with half-life alex like
did you advocate for rhys darby to play
russell for example
it was he
you were is of when you were writing it
well i reese darby didn't actually enter
into my so my very first thought
was
i really wanted nate bargetsky who we
eventually used in desk job to be uh
russell
uh it wasn't like i was debating between
rhys darby and nate bargetsky that was
who i had in my head in the very
beginning but it turned out there was
some stuff happening that we couldn't
nate couldn't do it and then we were
like oh what are we going to do
uh and then we were thinking about it
and
uh we we all like that was uh me and jay
and uh sean vanaman was also uh
the three of us were writing
alex and so reese it's not like he was
our second choice he was just an
orthogonal choice once nate bargetsi
couldn't do it we weren't weighing the
two of them
uh and so we we
got in touch with his people and he was
like sure uh happy to do it
and it'll work out
it did work out he was uh he was great
he was a nice guy he was based in los
angeles i thought we were gonna have to
go to new zealand uh which i've always
wanted to do
but uh he maybe is based in new zealand
now i remember
i think probably not he's he alternates
so i think he he's mainly based in l.a
but then he comes back to new zealand i
think every now and then because
obviously he does a lot of hollywood
films so
yeah probably why he's based in l.a i
don't know where that new show he's in
is filmed uh
but uh it was crazy because we jay and i
were in
i when we go to los angeles we were did
all his recordings in person in los
angeles maybe one we did remote but um
uh i never know where we are we're in
like we weren't are we in burbank or i
don't i never have a clear picture of
where we are but anyway we were
near the hotel just wandering around
killing time before the session
and just walking down the street i don't
know just some random area and there
here comes rhys darby just walking up
towards us we just met him on the street
with his wife
and he uh had no idea didn't remember us
from the first session so that uh didn't
know who we were uh seemed real nervous
when we were like we're just we're gonna
see you in an hour
uh
but he was um
yeah he was great
yeah
so how was the writing process for
half-life alex because
from what it sounds like that went
through
quite a substantial change
yeah from from the initial stages to the
end product
yeah that was a that was different than
any of the
stuff
you know
different similar uh different in the
fact that there was a jay and i had left
valve
um
right around the time alex
was first starting
uh when it was
not much was
it was it was pr in a real small
formative state
and as it started going along they
brought in they hired a writer
uh at valve
and he was working on story and they had
a whole game based around this story
uh
i mean it wasn't finished but it was
finished enough that you could play it
and
um
they started play testing it with the
whole company and the feedback was is
pretty
you know all this is great but the
doesn't seem like the story is working
like that was a common
thread and so
i don't remember the exact sequence of
events but there was a whole thing where
they're like well we're either gonna
have to scrap this
and we can't
we're not going to restart so we've got
all this track
uh
that kind of tells a story
but the story that's there isn't working
so
you know they asked well sean was
already there he was and jay was back
full-time he he only left when he left
it was almost like a sabbatical more
than than quitting or something but um
uh
and so
they were like we're gonna can you
write
us can you pitch us a story
that this was desean and jay and then
they got me involved um
because i had i was already a little bit
back at that point because jay and i i'd
come back as a contractor to work on the
aperture hand lab with jay and then uh
cloudhead games which was a
contractor anyway
uh they were like can you pitch us a
story
that will more or less fit with what we
have here
and then uh
yeah can you do that so i came out to
valve and we sat in a room for a couple
of weeks
and tried to figure out something that
would make sense
you know it didn't have to be exact like
we were going to have some ability to
make some new cuts you know have cut
scenes and
uh not cut scenes you know the alex
thing where there's sort of a choreo
scene um
you know so there was a budget
and by budget it's not i don't mean
monetary budget it's more just like
people's time and so that this will ship
you know this century
uh
and
uh so we did it we we sat in a room
we came up with something took us about
two weeks and then right before i left
we got up in front of the team which was
big at that point it was like
i want to say it was like 80 80 people
or at least 80 people there and we pitch
almost fully the story that ended up in
the game we made some i mean not like
line by line but the major beats of
everything
right and they were like let's do it uh
and so then i can't remember exactly i
feel like
there was a year it was maybe a year
after that pitch meeting i could
actually look it up because since i'm a
contractor i have to account for my
hours so the nice thing is i have almost
like a little diary of it what i did
every day um
but i want to say it was a year or a
year and a half that we spent after that
just getting it getting it all done but
did it stay this like from its initial
stages when when you guys came on
was all of the original story trashed
or were there little threads that still
stayed like was that definitely was the
ending always
it was not exactly the way it was but it
was
it was in broad stroke he had so the
broad stroke story was the g-man is
captured
and you go and you
let him out that was and that's the part
that we kept but there were other
characters and there was some other
stuff happening
um but the broadest stroke of
we're going to start in city 17
uh
you and you know and that alex would be
that was one of the immovable objects as
alex is the main character
or the viewpoint character
and it's going to end in a vault
where you will let the g-man go
but that was kind of the
the the one of the biggest problems was
what would happen once you let him out
that that was a piece that people were
dissatisfied with in in the form that it
was in and i don't even remember what
what it was at that point but
and the problem was
you've got
you you kind of let satan or god or
whatever you want to call him out of
prison like you do a big favor for
for
uh satan and what does he give you in
return it should probably be something
monumental uh
and so you know the ending is it
that that is that ending
was what we pitched um and you know that
was the part you were building towards
this and and in the pitch and we're like
oh boy you know because it could be
when you first hear it you're like oh
uh
it's but then
yeah it turned out fine uh
some of it was just
it was kind of
we had to
if they hated it from top to bottom this
was literally our
the best pitch we had you know we
weren't we didn't have a plan b so uh it
might have entailed if everybody had
really hated it it probably would have
maybe killed the pro i i don't know
exactly what would happen luckily it it
uh
it went through and then you know then
there was a bunch of work after that so
yeah
yeah one day of uh
of of thrilling excitement and then uh a
year and a half of of grinding it out
yeah but i'm sure valve is aware
uh obviously of like the half-life three
you know
propaganda and everything i mean gabe
must be over being asked that question
every time he does an interview but like
were you trying to like
lay little threads or connect the dots
to half-life 2 was that always the the
intention
i don't know if that was always the
uh
you know it came from because we were
struggling with the ending as well i
can't remember
if i've mentioned this or not but
you know that that was a big problem
like we cracked
to our mind a lot of the
tick tock of getting to the vault and
then we were like well we're still left
with this unsatisfying you know what
happens at the end
and uh
uh one of the artists jim murray i was
coming just riding up in an elevator
with him
and uh
i'm like i just laid out the problem
briefly because it was elevator right
and he's like
you know what if
uh
i can't remember exactly how he phrased
it but what if
the g-man
saves um
eli i was like that's idiotic but then i
started thinking about it and i was like
that's actually not bad it's like
uh
and then i went and
again
it was just because i was in luck of the
draw to have jim murray randomly
spouting out an idea that i like uh and
then i pitched it that morning to
uh i think uh it was jay and jay and
sean
and
you know they
it's everybody who heard it
initially resisted it for about 30
seconds until
they let it kind of sink in
uh
and then
it just seemed like once again it it
solved a lot of problems and it was
a big
you know it was actually something
worthwhile like you you got
you got us
oh there's a giant bug on my diet oh
look at that
whoo
uh
nope now it's gone um
so yeah i i don't even know what the
question was anymore but that's just it
was more more like tying tying it back
to half-life too i suppose
yeah i
it wasn't no it wasn't uh always going
to be tied back to half-life too in fact
that was the biggest ask
uh
in terms of new
content
was this ending because
none of that was there before now we're
like well can you make a
a version of the half-life 2 ending
scene you got to bring dog back and i
think jim murray ended up having to do
that work that was his punishment for
coming up with the idea because he had a
remodeled dog
but that was a that was that did not
exist other than conceptually you know
or more than conceptually concretely
that scene existed in half-life 2
uh but
did not
you know we did none of it was in alex
so people had to remake that whole thing
so yeah that was a big ask
just in terms of content and time
was just crazy that the genesis of it is
an elevator ride
yeah you never know uh
that's good i that's one thing that you
don't get with
with covid and zoom is just
so many good things come out of people
just being together and talking about
things
yeah which is something you miss uh you
miss with the zoom stuff
so what's your relationship like with
gabe like would he ever sit in with like
the writers
at any point or did he just let you do
your thing because i know when i spoke
to josh she mentioned that some of the
designers like oh my gosh
yes take down notes or everything he
says
yeah i think
he
gabe's
like
involvement with the day-to-day
production
predates by some amount me even showing
i showed up a couple chet and i showed
up together like
the week that half-life 2 shipped so
november 2004 and gabe was already not
involved in the day-to-day production so
i mean he's interested and
i i'm friendly with i'm not
uh i mean everybody's a little bit
scared of gabe but i'm not like i'm
happy to have a convert you know talk to
him
uh
i i
feel like i can send him mail email
without it being weird or you know
something like that but um
i like talking to him uh but no he was
not involved in the writing and we
didn't uh
uh like solicit his opinion on things
right you know he's he's doing
he's got a lot doing things yeah he's
he's uh yeah he's doing all his things
uh
which don't involve uh sitting in with
me and jay and listening to us be idiots
so yeah he's got way more important
things to do
yeah so with the writing are you
what writing on a laptop are you writing
with
with a pen like and you just got a
massive stack of paper paper with it
no
whiteboard like what do you use
sometimes where we will sketch things
out on a whiteboard but
uh
you know i'm i'm
usually writing if i'm writing by myself
which i'm not a huge fan of then i'm
just writing on google docs or word or
something
but
if i'm in the room it's usually i mean
the way we typically work is
uh
uh jay is typing and making it sound
like jay's chase
does everything while i well i stand
back uh which is sort of true um but so
we're we're
talking and talking and jay's writing
although sometimes
we both have an idea and we're we're
it's not like competing ideas it's like
jay's having an idea i'm having an idea
and he's like just write it just write
it down and so then i'm in which is one
nice thing about google docs is uh
you're both sort of yeah you know
everybody's in there together writing
uh
yeah so but yeah it's something it's on
the computer i am not writing anything
by hand
so out of all the characters that you've
written do you have like a particular
favorite
or one that was the easiest to write
oh
i'm trying to think
yeah i don't know maybe not i guess
they're all hard
well
they're all hard to a certain extent i
would like it if they were yeah i guess
the one that weirdly is closest
that where it just flows more naturally
to
my particular
uh
taste would be like the
kind of institutional voice and portal
to
the
the male voice that just talks
oh yeah i know though yeah
not even saying that's my favorite
character at the end of the day but that
is probably the thing that is easiest
was always easiest to write
um
and but in terms of writing like the
stuff that
you know like tf2
blog posts and things like that
flow pretty naturally because that's
just
my prose writing style so that that
stuff is
is fun to write and isn't
you agonize over it a little bit but
it's not
yeah it's just very natural to write
also the prose writing you don't have
there's no layer of abstraction between
you and the final product like there is
with when someone's going to act it you
need to make sure
there's a lot of times when you write
something even now years and years later
we get in the studio and we're like what
we're you know no human can can say
these this is idiotic uh this is just
terrible
most of these sessions are
us you know
50 of us apologizing to the actor for uh
making them say these words and then
we'll quickly rewrite it
it's just it's a crazy blind spot i
think everybody has it is you just you
write stuff and it seems decent enough
on the page and it's just
very clear once somebody says it out
loud
which is weird too because typically
we're
jay and i are just talking the whole
time i mean we're saying the lines you
know yeah that's i was going to ask i
was like yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah you would think i don't know i
can't explain it
so but then sometimes but sometimes it's
it's the person who says it right or an
accent
like
a certain accent can maybe make
something or a piece of dialogue sound
way cooler or better than
if a certain other accent is used
there's just also words that
actors have just never said or don't say
well like nate bargetsi
crushed it loved him loved working with
him but turret was just a word he had
never set which is unfortunate because
turret is something that's a central
component of aperture desk jobs so we
just kind of had to
work through that um
and some uh stuff we do
with portal has a convoluted style that
has some
where we will have to work a line a
little bit more because we want you to
say these ridiculous
words
you know semi-technical
stuff but we want you to say it with
some authority like you you're not
you know this isn't the first time
you've ever these words have ever uh you
know left your mouth or entered your
head so
uh
in those cases that that is an acting
problem that we will solve as opposed to
just rewriting
rewriting it
right
that makes perfect sense though
but it's a i suppose it's a good good
challenge to have
i mean do you
do you do you get to a point now where
if you're playing a game or even if
you're watching a film actually where
you're
kind of
zoning in or honing in on the on the
writing
i mean i guess everybody
is
i mean not
not so so i mean i have taste just like
anybody if i'm watching something and i
don't like it you know i
i just don't like it but i i guess more
of a thing would be
i think about how much work
it took to do something like i i
specifically remember playing god of war
and really enjoying it but while you
know during the week that i spent
playing god of war i was having these
stress dreams because
it was
thinking about
the pain it must have taken to make that
game because it's all so huge and
polished and uh it must have just been
i'm so happy i i had nothing to do with
that game uh but also you know i enjoyed
playing it
uh so i guess that's more the thing is i
just look at stuff and think about how
much work it must have been to do it
hmm
so how do you stay
uh stress-free
i don't i'm stressed all the time
i mean i'm not super stressed now
because i'm not working yeah
but um
even during desk job which was fairly
low stakes low stress i was telling josh
i
uh
you know josh and i have a zoom call
maybe once a week or something and i'm
like i'm right back in it like i'm
having stress streams and it's stressful
uh
but that's i mean that's just
i you know before when i was doing
database work that was stressful too
anybody if you have some amount of
pride or you care about what you're
doing you know it's going to be
stressful to do it i think but yeah i
suppose particularly in the case where
you've got
millions of people that are going to see
your work or witness yeah i guess
there's that too there is that although
that that's i i wonder sometimes though
because i i because i was almost as
stressed out doing the database stuff
which only
you know the client and then you know
the people you work with would see and
that was the more stressful part for me
always was letting down those because
the millions of people out there are
sort of it's a weird abstraction you
know it's just kind of like
hey you you do what you do i mean i i
want it to
be well received but
you're more like trying to not let down
the people that you're working with
uh you want to do a good job
yeah which is fair enough so in terms of
your writing if you had to critique your
own writing would you like what would be
the thing you'd like to improve most on
i mean i'd like it to be just better in
general uh but
you know we we rely on we have crutches
and
ticks that we use all the time uh
you know we've got these
comedic obsessions
i was just talking to jay about it a
couple of months ago because they come
out the best job our big comedic
obsessions are
getting fired
owing
a lot of money to dangerous people and
going to prison those three things crop
up all the time uh
i guess i'm not i don't know if i would
change it because i still enjoy thinking
about it and writing stuff about it but
you know and there's character traits
that if you look at it
you know the actor can change things you
try and make them different but you know
we'll write cave johnson lines
and i'll be like that's just sex and
hail like
those two are very similar so you know
you're like be nice if those two
characters were wildly different but you
know your brain
is only as good as your brain is and and
mine's
you know okay but not
you know uh it's it's not the best i
don't have the best for me so uh you
know we end up reusing things a lot
um
you know and anything comes out of your
own head is typically not startlingly
new to you right like it's kind of
although if you go back and revisit
something you did
15 or 20 years ago it suddenly seems
like something somebody else did and
you're like wow i wish i was that good
still
because this stuff is awesome
uh
hmm
have you ever recorded uh or had an
actor record a piece of dialogue
and then the designers are like no we're
not including that and you're like god
damn it this is like so good such a good
line
oh yeah uh although we will typically
try and rework it if it's like a
gag that's even slightly uh reusable
somewhere else we'll usually try and
repurpose it at least writing-wise and
re-record it but yeah tons of stuff gets
thrown out
um
but i guess that would be another thing
i would like to
write with have the same effect but with
the half as many words uh that but it's
just hard it's harder well writing's
just a hot art form anyway
yeah i mean it's all i i look at with
everybody it's all hard i look at what
the artists do and i
genuinely like i think they look at what
we do and they're like well i write i
can kind of do that but i look at what
they do like jim murray or any of the
valve artists uh and i'm like i don't
even know where you would start to to do
this stuff how does that go from your
head
to the paper the wacom tablet or
whatever i
no clue
it's a complete like magic trick to me
so but when you're writing are you
seeing like a visual in your head you
must be like picturing some sort of
image yeah sometimes uh that's a that's
a weird not a weird question it's a good
question i've never really thought about
before
uh
yeah i don't know
like could you write something and then
maybe pitch it to the artist somewhat
like have you ever done that yeah
sometimes we will uh
you know we'll think that it would be
good if
this scene was sort of surrounded by
something like i think
i i want to say that but i don't know
that this is actually the case but let's
just pretend it is for the moment i
think like at the end of your desk job
you
go up into cave's office and he's just a
big cement head
and i
think that's something jay and i came up
with and then we pitched to the artists
so there was something that was you know
gags that are sort of visual
along with you know just just the words
uh
but if that wasn't the case there if one
of the artists came up with the head
thing there's there are other cases like
that that's an example of something that
where we might come up with the visuals
um and
we
and again this is jay more than me we do
these team fortress comics and jay's a
much i'm not a comic guy at all uh
but jay's a huge comic fan and so he
very del like we'll write it together
and then he panels them out using just
like
clip art and stuff and he will panel it
out in a general way for the artist to
be like here's kind of what i'm thinking
for this panel and this panel and this
panel so there's a much more direct
connection to the stuff we do with
comics uh in terms of
uh describing visually what what's gonna
ah
that's cool
that's cool that you're able to convey
it like because
some people
they're not able to necessarily convey
in their head
jesus
yeah
he's not an artist but he's a good
designer like he's actually really good
like
he knows photoshop better than a lot of
the artists do he's good at just general
i don't know what you call it just
design but he's also really good at
paneling out the uh the comics he just
knows a lot about comics i've learned a
lot
about how comics work because i
literally knew nothing about how comics
worked uh before we started doing comics
yeah so what was your involvement with
the steam deck then what did you do was
it like just programming stuff
oh the steam deck yeah no no we we just
i mean
aperture desk job was part of the steam
deck so that was all we did yeah i had
nothing to do with any any of the rest
of it right okay absolutely all the the
rest of that stress was on everyone else
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah uh that's why
you know desk job was free it came with
the steam deck like
it that's why there should have been no
stress but you want it to be great like
you want to be like this needs to be
awesome so let's let's try to make it
really awesome uh yeah yeah
uh which involves you know a lot of work
a lot of thinking about it hmm now is it
true that you want to sunset overdrive
too
i do i like sunset yeah i love sunset
overdrive uh
sure i i don't think i'm ever going to
get it but i would like it uh you know
people microsoft don't you
don't i don't i don't i know people who
know people at microsoft i'm one degree
of separation uh
away from them but i
yeah i don't know i like microsoft the
gaming industry is actually quite small
though in terms of the people that
actually work within it i would think
yeah it's like it feels like that's
still small yeah yeah like it's all
interconnected
it's small in the sense that if i
haven't met everybody
which i haven't
um
i uh
i could probably
know somebody who knows them like yeah
probably you're a couple days away from
getting in contact with almost anybody i
mean there's probably people in maybe
the japanese end of the business that it
would be harder to get in contact with
but yeah
uh but yeah it's small in that sense uh
and i think you know you never
there always seems to be
once you're established to a certain
amount i don't know what it would take
for you to be like drummed out of the
industry entirely so because you know
they always need people
uh
so it's small in in that sense
if you have you taken on like more of a
contractor role and not a permanent
staff member
primarily to just kind of take a step
back
so you can kind of um
that would be originally saying
we just needed uh because my wife needed
her uh he needed to
uh take care of her mom and so we needed
to move back to cleveland and it was
kind of the right time
but there's also just some legal stuff
with valve where you to be a full-time
employee it's just you need to live
in washington state washington yeah uh
that might change that
that might change
i don't know what i don't know the whole
reasoning behind it uh
but i also do
it's nice to just
be able to kind of drop in when there's
something that's interesting
uh and then not
uh
be there if i don't have to be there or
feel like i need to
do something you know fill my day if
there's nothing going on that i really
want to work on
yeah
well you are a trooper um i mean josh
mentioned to me that like you were you
had a child well well
portal 2 was shipping like you're in the
middle of like
we have about stressful
yeah our son was born
almost a year to the day before portal 2
ship so that last year was uh oh my god
i do remember that
one thing i was giving josh some crap
about it uh he kind of made it sound
like i was just storming around the
house and my wife beat her with a
cigarette hanging on my mouth telling my
wife that this is how things are gonna
be it was a discussion we were like
because i was at the time
i was like
look we can
and this isn't a passive regret like we
need to make a decision here like either
if i'm gonna finish
portal two i think it'll be good for us
ultimately uh
but i'm gonna you you know she knows me
uh we've been together for 30 years or
whatever uh
i'm gonna have to commit to this fully
because it's a ton of work
and
uh you know she was she quit her job
when you know the last couple of months
of her pregnancy and thanks to valve she
didn't have to work anymore if she
didn't want to but i was like
we can
pack it up right now and this would
actually be fine be a relief uh i like
finishing things but another great
pleasure of mine is walking away from
things when in the middle of things
being really difficult uh i was like we
can go
back to minnesota you can get a nursing
job there
you know we've saved up because i always
think that we're gonna i'm gonna get
fired any second so we were pretty
frugal we had a bunch of money saved we
could live for the first year or two of
jack's life and then
i'm going to be unemployable because i
have no real marketable skills outside
this weird little niche but you're she's
a nurse
i'll stay home with jack and you can
you know you can work but yeah we she
nope it was uh
she we we made the decision that that
first year and it was it turns out to be
a good move that first year i don't know
if you have any kids but it's a blur you
won't remember it anyway
um not yet but i will
soon enough so uh you will not remember
that first year uh and then once portal
2 shipped
it was never that intense
again
so uh and it afforded us the ability to
you know she could stay home she didn't
want to have a job she didn't have to
have a job so
uh yeah it's all good she does not it
was a mutual decision mutually agreed
upon so yeah mutually agreed even though
it was hard okay good good clarification
it was hard although the divisional
labor i mean it was hard but it was
hard for you know i wasn't off at the
strip clubs every night i was working
hard she was working hard we were both
working hard
uh so she at least didn't feel like i
was slacking off yeah yeah and i didn't
feel like she was slacking huh and jack
was a good baby so that it was fairly it
was really simple it worked out fine
yeah
oh hey i'll i'll uh i'll wrap up there
thank you thank you so much for taking
the time out
yeah
fun farm time farm time so back to the
farm or i'm gonna get in the car and
drive home we'll see
yeah so if anyone wants to keep up to
date with what you're doing although
from what i understand you're a bit of
an undercover guy
you kind of lay low you're not big on
social media
no i mean i will go through a period of
two or three days where i have fun
tweeting but it all social media
is fire and forget for me because i
don't really wanna i just wanna post
something and then not engage with it so
i'll post something and then not look at
it anymore uh
but yeah you could follow me on twitter
that people are subscribed to me on
twitter but don't expect a lot of tweets
uh and that's it that's all my things uh
that i do uh i think i'm on facebook
maybe but i think that's just
uh my family
uh and that's it what else would there
be oh instagram i'm not on instagram
uh
i don't do anything well that's good i
actually think uh people that aren't on
social media tend to have a
clearer mind on things or the value
system tends to be different usually
because they're spending their time
doing other things as opposed to yeah i
don't want to meet me
on social media yeah i'm talking i'm
talking and i do this so okay i don't i
don't i'm not using my time not uh you
know working in a soup kitchen or
anything with my social media time i'm
playing slave aspire probably but uh i
uh
yeah i i'm not i don't make it sound
like i'm better than anybody who's on
social media it's just not as um
i don't get a ton of satisfaction out of
it
well thanks thanks for your time thanks
for everything you've done in terms of
your writing i hope maybe you get to a
point where
you're not stressed
when you're
when you're working oh i like the stress
i don't know something no i don't like
the stress but it seems to be a part of
the uh that just comes with the
territory yeah it's just what it what
happens it's fine uh i'm used to it at
this point
um
but
yeah we've gotta
uh
start portal three that's my message to
um
let's make it happen to whoever if you
get anything you can do let's do it
let's just make it
listening
because uh yeah i am i am also not
getting any younger like we are we are
reaching the point where it's crazy to
think literally gonna be too old to work
on portal uh three so we should just do
it and desk job is fun if you like desk
job send mail to gabe
tell them you want some portal three uh
it won't do anything
but maybe it'll make you feel you never
know well if you get spammed with emails
but uh maybe it'll be worth it i don't
know yeah
all right cool all right well that's the
show everyone make sure you share like
and subscribe uh
start the petition for portal 3
and uh until next time stay safe see you
later
[Music]
you